[Musique]
mais pour paris et en ile et vous ça
n'irait pas avec n'importe qui où mène
pour toi
les gens qui connaissent comme moi qui
les ont élevés c'est moi qui les ai
élevés c'est le compagnie pour moi
qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient donc jeu
rapide et passer tous les temps du rétro
ballon tendu m pour que quelque chose
pour me distraire mais m voyez le comme
elle me pose en compagnie oui vous avez
votre mari a malheureusement que je n'ai
pas tout le temps il y avait un jour un
petit peu d'offres qui paye pour tout le
temps c'est bon les combinés tonnes vous
êtes avec lui soixante trois ans je suis
marié ne m'aime 3 mai 1914 ya 23 ans
soixante trois ans alors c'est un défi
c'est long on a des petits mots dans un
temps on se dispute mais ça n'est pas
bien grand non c'est pas anglais
non non non non c'est la maison vous
avez vécu ça toute votre vie il aimait
nina vous avez jamais voulu partir je
suis parti en guerre tout même si j'ai
eu des bâlois away gt1 que tulle kirkouk
totino pendant la guerre j'ai été
pendant la guerre
j'étais en italie j'étais en bulgarie en
ciel be vous connaissez tous à vous
voilà tu as ma tête avec 7 tout le
tacite on y voit du monde allait le
voile avec target cattori intensif
l'état qui taquinent co2 c'est ben oui
james kok 4 les petits conseils single
de personnes j'ai fait un bain du voyage
personne aujourd'hui si ce fait est
obligé d'y faire cette course ouverte
puis savaria coûté un prix 25 août et je
ne sais pas combien ils se voyaient
alors je tâte et d'une parole mais nous
quand on pas la tête avec tag est de 14
alors là c'est fini
il envoie le lit quand même il obéit aux
pas si l'obésité n'est pas suffisamment
de tartous évidemment
puis quand je lui dit d'aller se coucher
libre je vais si vous travaillez temps
en temps à tout va c'est sûr qu'en dites
vous à propos de voir les gars aient
bien pris va m'énerver à leur salaire
qui va pas sans soulever son dîner bon
et qu'est ce que tu vas te coucher tu
manges portable il est difficile
ou qu'il est difficile tous ont déjà
m'accorder pour leurs nouvelles moi mon
nom villa jamais jamais manqué de la
brioche et puis lui il avait la nouvelle
ou la wii alors teint hâlé pourquoi
parce qu'ils enterrent 10h30
c'était pas 10h30 avant de l'ennemi pour
moi tu étais désolé
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe nous sommes
là les attend dans la sous- renard qui
pesait mais vous n'avez jamais réussi à
la corde et vauban
pourquoi il voulait pas changer epex que
s'il voulait pas pour épater les seniors
i moi vous ne voulez pas d'ailés la
veille quel est le le plus beau moment
de votre vie
c'est honteux on s'est mariés mais voilà
en 14 13 14
pourquoi vous l'avez vous pas parce que
j'étais la guerre qui allait arriver et
puis valère quelqu'un à temps pour
garder tout le matériel
mais le paiement mais pourquoi vous
l'avez choisie elle
fallait il en fallait une partie tempo
de la baltique mais il est tellement
gentil il montrait tout ce que je veux
[Musique]
et